Have a dream of '
I am here, people are standing here,
roaming freely without any apology, if there are no
guidelines to be followed then there is
no point, it is being said again and again that you people should
settle down, tell me what will the government do, it
is the fault of us people.  Not that we
should follow but there is no problem here,
no one is ready to listen to anything,
we have requested all of you to follow the excellent line,
even from us it is possible that you
also maintain efficient distances, the protocol
which  That the blasts should hang him, it is
not a show piece, it is a follower of any kind,
people from India have come here, there is
no proper infection of the same thing,
this is everyone's thing and everyone
has wealth in their mind, but I pray to God for this.  We
will do this, we will keep the hope that by
doing this quickly, we will get
freedom from what has been killed and born, and we will
continue to live life like the first day, today is a
very sacred day, today is the day that
Kapil Muni, after taking a bath in Ganga,  If we visit the
Ganga and bathe in the Ganges and do cow-dows, we
get very virtuous results. Come, do a
show,
do a peacock. The
water of my dreams has come here by bringing water from here. If
it is organized in this way,
then it will lead to progress.  What is above is after that,
here we will
not be more than 500 after maintaining the successful list. If given, the
person who was standing has gone, the second test will come,
hence, we had tried our best not to do in the class.
music] turn it
on
[praise] do it